to start with the question and the first
goes to the U un correspondent
Association president please Miriam
thank you thank you so much and on
behalf of the United Nations
correspondent Association thank you Mr
Minister for this press conference uh my
question is you said that Russia will
not forget and will not forgive the U.S
of denying Uh Russian journalist visas
to come to the U.N and follow your visit
uh what does it mean and can you
elaborate on that please
foreign
appalling
information
[Music]
France
Amendment to the United States
apparently means nothing
[Music]
um
abuse
views
[Music]
thank you
thank you Mr Farmers I'd like to ask you
your views on Sudan and what's happening
there and also about the involvement of
the Wagner group with the
rabbit support forces we asked hamiti
the leader of this group about the
involvement of Wagner with him and his
forces and he did not deny it
um and just the last question to whom
are they accountable this group is it to
the Russian government to another body
who are they accountable to thank you
basis
accommodated
first
for us
[Music]
to
provide foreign
so
okay
geopolitics
negotiations
[Music]
of those countries African solutions to
Africa problems
thank you Minister lavrov uh Michelle
Nichols from Reuters thank you so much
for the briefing
um I just wanted to ask you a little bit
further about the Ukraine grain deal and
whether
Russia has a response yet to the letter
that the Secretary General has sent to
President Putin suggesting a way forward
for the extension and expansion of this
Ukraine grain deal and China is the
biggest recipient of the Ukraine grain
under that deal so has China asked
Russia to extend the deal
as foreign
[Music]
ammonia
a commercial initiative foreign
he tried to
um
[Music]
fertilizer in Russia foreign
and indeed one of the banks
foreign
[Music]
fertilizers
companies
[Music]
um
structures
so
um
it doesn't sound like you see a lot of
Hope for an extension of the Black Sea
grain deal
s
so Russia
to give it to uh
the Russian government does not
interfere in the Affairs of other states
yes thank you very much thank you
foreign minister for the briefing it's
Pamela Falk from CBS News
you talked about yesterday and a year
ago about the inadmissibility of the
expansion of NATO and yet because of the
war Finland has become a member of
Sweden's next and these NATO Secretary
General is supporting Ukraine's
membership
was it a miscalculation and where do you
see the reasons now for the war since
the NATO border with Russia has now
doubled thank you not the initis
um
[Music]
but we were also promised on several
occasions
friends
[Music]
to begin negotiations this is
discrimination persecution and the
threat of extermination
foreign
[Music]
and
did
back in their days
practically all cultural contracts
between our countries
take a look also what is happening with
the Ukrainian Orthodox Church
[Music]
similar to what happened yesterday
uh promised you guaranteed just 24 hours
before the coup that you would find a
settlement
to this extent and they just said well
sometimes
[Music]
hello
thank you Matthew chance from CNN Miss
lavrov
um
could you give us some details about
what contact you may have had with U.S
officials about the fate of U.S citizens
being held in in Russian Jails of any
contacts been had have they been sought
and
also secondly there have been prisoner
swaps in the past
can you speak louder yeah sorry there
have been prisoner swaps in the past
what are you looking for in exchange for
poor Whelan and Evan gershkovich
um
did not provide foreign
pretty
[Music]
um
being able to commit crimes or something
which we reject there are many examples
[Music]
there was a campaign
nobody mentions
approximately 60 people here
[Music]
accusations are dubious and on a number
of occasions
understandable and there's no need to
tell you professionals about why
oh thank you Minister here this is
between the Turkish news agency anadolo
uh recently president the Turkish
president invited President Putin to
Turkey for the inauguration of uh
turkey's first nuclear power reactor
which was built by a Russian Energy
company thus President Putin planned to
visit Turkey on the 27th of April thanks
yes
the importance of such a meeting
just quickly back to the Ukraine
agreement
um
oh I'm Caleb moppin from RT
um I'm asking Russia has repeatedly
pointed out that Ukraine is not
fulfilling its obligations under uh the
grain deal
um and my question is uh does Russia
intend to withdraw from the deal or is
there is there a reason for staying if
they're not going to fulfill their
obligations
is
[Music]
specifically
president recently made statements to
the effect of uh Beijing doesn't want
peace in Ukraine that they benefit from
the status quo what is moscow's position
on this
relate to the rest of duration in China
this is a reflection of the current
mindset and mentality
I'm with RTE Ireland there are nearly 80
000 Ukrainian refugees currently in
Ireland do you apologize to them for
having to leave their homes fleeing your
war and secondly is China your friend
and if it is your friend why aren't they
sending you weapons
why are they sending why aren't they
China or aren't aren't
you
foreign
using those rights
and Russian federations
sure that it aligns
[Music]
get this device
but
[Music]
substance
thank you
millions of people then reflect to the
Russian Federation
[Music]
leader of democracy
thank you ourselves
[Music]
New York
day one has many goals like increase its
goals all the time but the main goal in
1945 was to prevent
World War III
and for 70 or 75 years we have been able
to you know has been able to reach this
goal
I heard your speech yesterday at the
security Council and looks like you are
not confident I don't think you're
confident anymore that this institution
can prevent
Another World War so my question is
why you are not confident and
what the Secretary General does I have
any role because for example Lula the
president of Brazil day you just you
just visited Brazil
it's okay it's still a question the
question is yeah the question is what do
why the Secretary General didn't is we
did not seeing him doing the same thing
the others do and they're coming up with
a plan
the Secretary General of un is not
coming with a plan for peace because you
are not going to even look at it or is
not doing it because he can't do it
well why don't you ask him
I've been asking about it but that's
interesting can I start answering okay
learning
this year
but he has said that
if we help you
around
the statement of your own presence
[Music]
would not hesitate to push thread button
s
the foreign
[Music]
we're prepared
once again Americans
[Music]
under presidents
audience
I hope that the people making these uh
in their sound mind in the end that they
show responsibilities
[Music]
today
very emotionally about how much
years
left to work with
[Music]
well I think foreign
foreign
[Music]
answer your
name
[Music]
this is
um
thank you
um Amanda at CNBC after February 24th by
many tallies Russia is the most
sanctioned country in the world do you
think Western sanctions are working and
can your country withstand more economic
pressures
I remember back
2010 I think Barack Obama said um
[Music]
Russia's economy
was already in in shreds
[Music]
it doesn't change
private
those governments now trying to come
back
we're not sure that we
there is businesses
[Music]
National currencies
going forward
[Music]
globalization
basis of
[Music]
um
about how to gain independence of those
who have been governing the
International Financial system so far
minister with China central television
first a quick follow-up on the green
deal
you just talk a lot about the nature
whether it's a commercial or
humanitarian
do you think that Russian has been
fooled in the beginning to sign this
deal and my question is you talk a lot
about a new world order uh which has
been resonated yes Yesterday by the
member states like Brazil
um can you tell us why the international
multi-polar World Order is better than
the current one especially for the you
know rule-based order by some of the
western colleagues and the most
importantly how you are going to
persuade your Western colleagues to
believe that thank you
and fertilizer
um
export
[Music]
in the United equals
possible
by leveraging questions
foreign
Europe
[Music]
um
clear underrepresentation of African and
Latin American countries thank you Maria
this is Miriam ramadi Afghanistan
International I have one question
regarding Afghanistan as you know the
Taliban recently have banned women from
working at the UN offices the Secretary
General is traveling to Doha to meet
with these Special envoys regarding
Afghanistan what do you think the next
step of the International Community be
regarding Afghanistan and also one
question about jcpoa do you think jcpoa
is dead thank you
Afghanistan
foreign
restore those assets
that's not a question foreign
[Music]
to in troduce yourself
to secure unilateral advantages my name
is
Mr Minister you spoke about the golden
billion
both gold and billion you spoke about it
and do you anticipate in the future to
see that the world is not only one
golden billion but eight golden billion
and the second is about the two-state
solution everyone repeated this slogan
two-state solution you know I think do
you still believe there is any chance
real chance to have an independent
contiguant sovereign
Palestinian State thank you
I think that um
[Music]
what about the Palestine Jewish
Israel which Israel is defending so
um
[Music]
when every two years one focuses on
elections
these are all the people who say black
lives matter
yes please
thank you Maria
greetings Mr Minister nice to see you
again
are you personally involved in any of
the negotiations
that would release prisoners
in America and in Russia for example
Evan gershkovich are you personally
involved
and I have another question which is
uh I it it looks like the Ukraine
admission
into NATO is not very realistic despite
what some people have said but as a
member of the EU it may be more feasible
what is your opinion on that
regarding the second question oh yeah
[Music]
um
foreign
fourth part of that territory and I've
been living there for hundreds of years
this is what the EU looks like currently
um
for many years has been in negotiations
yeast
two
yeah
[Music]
there is very little difference
currently between us
is
statement to the extent that this would
all be important for our billion and
that's
that's yeah
forgot to say who I am
thank you thank you very much Mr
Minister and uh
I know I speak on behalf of all of us
that when you're in New York we always
happy to have you here answering
questions from us Edith letter from the
Associated Press
um as you look ahead to the rest of this
year
uh what are your expectations for
um
the state of
peace and Security in the world
do you see
prospects for
negotiations or an end to the Ukraine
conflict to other conflicts Yemen Libya
um you set Sudan
um
what what are your hopes and
expectations
no place
for hopes and expectations
um
proclaims itself as for the rest
rictions
what are your expectations
President Obama when President
decided from behind
and put the European Union
[Music]
there will be progress on Yemen since
women and
um
elect
abulary
honestly splitting one's motives
what goals are they pursuing
in other places
where they optimistic
yes
[Music]
we should
placing one
no matter what traditions
justified by yeah
we spoke just now about our third world
war who wants this is
can I ask a quick question about nuclear
plant safety a nuclear plant safety in
Ukraine
nuclear plant safety in Ukraine
I'll just go